[Musique]
nous nous trouvons à la cabane de climat
ou dans une chocolaterie en pleine
préparation des fêtes de pâques et pour
en parler avec nous cécile lefrançois
bonjour bonjour alors j'imagine qu'en ce
moment vous êtes vous tourner à plein
régime pour préparer ces fêtes comment
ça se passe ces fêtes de pâques se
préparent en général très tôt après noël
parce que pâques est une
grand événement pour nous les
chocolatiers dans l'année c'est le
deuxième pour être très honnête donc ça
représente 20 % de notre activité à peu
près et du coup il faut pas faiblir
sortie de noël effectivement où on
s'attaque à pâques au prototype et puis
ensuite à la production si ça vous dit
je propose qu'on aille voir ce que vous
nous proposez ébats avec plaisir donc
cette année comme tous les ans
d'ailleurs on essaye de définir un thème
qui sortent un petit peu des sentiers
battus
de la cloche des lapins et des poules
cette année on a choisi aladin comme
thème est donc on voit là on a décliné
les personnages les sujets autour de ce
thème là baladins et bien c'est parti à
[Musique]
ou pas si c'est ici que se trouve le
gros de votre production exactement en
tout cas tous les sujets de thématiques
donc autour d'aladdin effectivement se
retrouvent ici
voilà donc vous avez l'oeuf mille et une
nuits ici qui ressemble à un mandala un
petit peu et donc qui rappelle un peu ce
côté exotique vous avez l'éléphant le
califat voilà donc une assez grosse
pièce effectivement
voilà et puis je vois le singe voilà le
petit à bouger ni le perroquet yago le
perroquet aussi la loi exactement la
lampe merveilleuse voilà vous avez le
tapis volant avec son petit dromadaires
et donc qu'est-ce qui fonctionne qu est
ce qui égalait la tendance un peu en ce
moment alors la tendance cette année
c'est vrai qu' on est un petit peu moins
sur les sujets classiques et vraiment il
ya un engouement sur ce sujet un peu
originaux un peu exotique voilà qui
rappelle le voyage pense que les gens en
ont marre en est donc ils se tournent
beaucoup vers ces sujets là il ya une
pièce maîtresse cette collation oui qui
se trouve justice il exactement la
caverne aux merveilles la caverne
d'aladdin la caverne qui dans lequel
dans laquelle aladin a trouvé sa petite
lampe merveilleuse et le génie qui lui
est associée on retrouve sur cette pièce
le tapis volant évidemment le trésor et
puis cette fameuse caverne donc c'est un
vrai travail d'orfèvre ce qu'elle a été
commandée cette pièce elle n'a pas
encore été commandée mais mais on a bon
espoir qu'elle le soit en tout cas moi
je vais réfléchir alors
[Rires]
[Musique]
le
donc on se trouve juste devant le
laboratoire oui tout à fait on a la
chance ici d'avoir le laboratoire
complètement
lle en lien avec la boutique en tout cas
est donc un retour client direct un
échange entre vraiment la production et
la boutique c'est ça qui est intéressant
ici
[Musique]
ceci vous est ouverte depuis 2014 et
forcément la cabane de green ça nous
évoque un peu les comptes quelle est
l'histoire de ce magasin alors moi je
suis
une grande enfant je suis resté enfant
en tout cas passionné les contes pour
enfants et
notamment des contes des frères grimm
donc j'ai voulu rendre hommage à
à ces écrivains
compteur en tout cas et voilà donc on on
a créé cette
boutique vraiment sur ce thème là donc
sur les étagères vous retrouverez des
lutins des faits voilà donc un monde un
peu fantastique un peu magique et
qu'il va bien je trouve donc depuis huit
ans maintenant nous occuper à vous
atteler à créer chocolat confiserie et
glace pour les petits et les grands
c'est ça tout à fait en espérant que ça
ravissent voilà les petits et les grands
en tout cas pour pâques ou même en tout
temps tout le monde peut venir ici merci
beaucoup mais ça ce style d'avant merci
à vous
[Musique]